good evening everybody welcome to fenway
park for game four the american league
divisional series and if the red sox win
they will move on to the league
championship series they lead this one
two games to one if tampa bay wins
tonight the two clubs will return to
tropicana field and saint petersburg
eduardo rodriguez 28 year old out of
venezuela really a second chance after
he failed to make it through the second
inning of game one
yeah second chance would be a great one
for the red sox they are in a position
where they can knock out the
rays randy arose arena always a threat
always dangerous driven to right center
field towards the gap renfro
launches and makes the play
running toward the red sox bullpen and a
bullet not hit very high in the air
renfro went a long way reached down
below his left knee and made a backhand
grab for the uh what a play wonder front
go up to phenom six for 15 in the series
recall he got it in there and franco's
really upset with a home plate umpire
ron culpa i think eddie got a break on
so red sucks get a break and here's
brandon lau swinging a miss by three got
him on a fast ball up and away and eddie
appears pumped tonight so the first man
on the mound for the race tonight is
colin mchugh the first of many they've
got just about everybody available it'd
be a bonus if he went three innings
let's just say that t.k hernandez right
hand batter hernandez punches one to
right a rosarena comes on and makes the
play
both right fielders with nice plays in
the first inning well i don't think it's
any mistake that the red sox offense
took off when they got j.d martinez back
goes after the first pitch kind of a
side-spinning liner and a sliding play
kevin kiermeier and defense all over the
place stealing the show early that's a
tremendous catch and risk by kermart
move to the top of the third and he's
been perfect over two austin meadows
leads off the ending 17th pitch
meadows succumbs to a slider
worth the weight eddie's fifth strikeout
never's level with the bag at third the
pitch to kiermeier is right at him
beautiful play on one hop to his hip
raffy throws to first inning over
mccube did a fine job two innings
without just one hit he's out after the
two shane mcclanahan makes his first
relief appearance of the year and
there's no sense in saving mcclanahan
for a game that may not come and how
about this hand for christian vasquez
vasquez with a base hit in the center to
lead off the third the red sox have him
at first and second that'll be up to
raffy devers swinging a high fly ball
into center field kier meyer back at the
wall kier meyer will watch it good
raffy devers three run homer to straight
away center
boy it scraped the sky and when it came
down the red sox lead three nothing
that's actually at 37 three-run homers
in the regular season to lead the world
rafael 10 of them and none bigger than
that one bogart's at first hugo smoked
the ball to center field his first time
it was caught here's a swing and a high
driving to left field off the bat of her
dugo it is high and it is off the wall
bogart comes to third he's gonna be
waved home the relay throw will not be
nearly in time it's a fenway wall ball
double for verdugo he rocks the baby at
second and it's four nothing red sox and
now 3-2 to martinez is hit in the air
left field towards the wall and another
baseball banging off the monster a long
single a five run third for the red sox
and that's gonna be it for shane
mcclanahan yes it's definitely all hands
on deck but that plan could go awry if
one guy does not have a good day and
shane mcclanahan has had a tough
appearance here he closed it third with
one gone from meadows their top rbi man
rounds it to first and that aggressive
play by luplow will get them their first
run and it's 5-1 boston two-man down and
here's zanino
and dribble down the first base line
grab by schwarber nicely to his left
steps on first to retire the side
eduardo rodriguez who failed to make it
through two innings in game one is
through five innings and has given up a
run on two hits pop-up down the line
charging hard but won't get there
and it gets by verdugo allowing
kiermeier to get into second so the
lead-off man aboard and in scoring
position back-to-back innings for tampa
bay he'll get a good hand from this
crowd who'll recognize the job that
eduardo rodriguez did such an up and
down career for him in boston
one of the high points right here in
game four the division series
i here's tanner hawk the winner in game
two he went five innings allowed just
one run one away in the six ray's trying
to get one more back wander franco their
best hitter in this postseason brexit in
the air to center field hernandez going
back on this one it is gone
franco and the rays say not so fast a
two-run game on a two-run shot from the
kid
wander franco with a two-run homer and
here come the rays it's 5-3 boston luis
poutino is in the game less than 24
hours after allowing the walk-off home
run martinez aboard with the lead-off
single and some bad memories for patino
because here is christian vasquez
slider again three consecutive slide
pieces from patino to win it this time
vasquez down on strikes back-to-back k's
in two hours bring ground ball to third
backhanded nicely by diaz bounces the
throw to first in time to retire the
side it must have taken three or four
bounces across the natural grass and
luplow looked back with a little disgust
at christian arroyo for kicking him in
the back of the leg wow as he was
crossing first base 5-3 boston one on
one out in the seventh does raffi have
one more bolt goes after it muscles it
into right center field and a dunk shot
base hit hernandez headed for third tier
myers throw not in time boston has him
cornered
raffy delivers again and the red sox
have them at the corners on comes pete
fairbanks one of the most dependable
flame throwing relievers and they've got
i mean the guy that has caused so much
damage to the race coming up xander
bogarts
bouncing ball to third they go to second
one louder first it's a double play
they go around the horn and they turn it
and they deny the red sox here in the
seventh inning
stands in second base and the tying run
comes to the plate in kiermeier
in the air to right center towards the
gap that'll split it back-to-back extra
base hits to open the eighth it's a
one-run game as kier meyer drives in
zanino
back-to-back doubles here in the eighth
inning and the rays have gotten this to
an n1 and just like that the rays have
the time run in scoring position for the
new mr october randy rosarina swing and
looper in the right field that's going
to get through for a base hit here by
her late break gets the third he's being
waved home throw to the plate too late
in the second base goes to rosarina the
rey's have come all the way back and
have tied this game at five randy
orozzareno with an opposite field base
hit three in a row for tampa bay to
greet brazier alex verdugo leading off
the eighth
punches to bounce it ashore
franco
into the dugout the door swings open for
boston while the made a mistake finally
he went to his right i think he had time
to set his feet and throw up the right
field side and troy the first baseman
couldn't deal with it there's one out
and now here's the ray's nemesis hunter
retro swing and a fly ball at a gap in
right center kier meyer coming over he's
going to make the catch verdugo is going
to tag here comes the throw to third he
is
out at third base they got him they got
him what a throw by caremeyer
and that the red sox just run themselves
out of the eighth inning it looked like
the initial read was
possibly safe
here
but watch it pop up
right there and that's where i think
they're going to get it as kevin
kiermeier gotten him out of the inning
he has
with some help from diaz
the red sox have run themselves out of
this eighth inning
both to walk it off we go to the bottom
of the ninth so the winning run is at
second base for travis shaw
bounce to third off the end of the bet
diaz throws low throw knock down he's
safe
a little dribbler diaz went to his right
he got there he threw low on a hop and
troy could not come up with it he
bobbled it on one hop a pinch runner
goes to third it's danny santana [ __ ]
hernandez
coming to the plate with a chance to cap
off this incredible division series
with a walk-off win on a no one pitch
hernandez
lifts
center field
it is pulled in by meadows here comes
santana the red sox under the
championship series
the red sox have won the division series
a sacrifice fly by kiki hernandez
bringing home danny santana with a
winning run
red sox walk it off six to five the red
sox ultimately get one in the bottom of
the ninth and they take this series
three games to one they're headed to the
american league championship series
nichola vulture organic seltzer as real
as it tastes